the nhl all-star game is coming on
saturday that means the convention
center it's really been transformed into
kind of an interactive fun hockey site
for fans yeah they've got a lot of stuff
for fans to do jc fernandez is live at
the nhl fan fair with an example of some
of the things you can do out there hi jc
hey guys this is an unbelievable
experience the stanley cup is out here
we had mascots doing dodgeball earlier
and the great thing is you can put your
skills to the test which is what i'm
about to do i'm gonna see if i can get
the puck into uh the dryer into the
washing machine and just you know i was
practicing earlier i did knock out the
um which is the lint trap so i do have
some skills we'll see how it goes here
all this stuff is included with
admission by the way
place your money now will the kid get in
get in in the uh
washer and dryer here we go
i gotta practice harder here we go three
two
ah can we get in the air
three two
oh i hit the thing that's not bad right
this is cool this is one of the skills
you can do let's walk down here we got
another skill down here come on guys
this is great for kids and the entire
family as well i'm gonna do one more
shot here can i slide in here try my
shot what because oh this guy's money
this guy is good
no i'm not going to follow this guy he's
on fire
there's no okay
oh he scored yeah you scored buddy they
wanted me to step in and follow him i'm
not going to follow that guy he's on
fire i'll send it back to you guys in
the studio coming up we're going to
check out the stanley cup
don't follow him yeah it's never you
never want to be like outshined by 10
year old which is kind of what was
happening well